à chaque rentrée scolaire c'est un
moment attendu par les enfants
redoutée par les parents l'achat des
fournitures scolaires cartables à la
mode ou agenda dernier cri depuis les
années 50 le marketing s'est emparée des
rayons et nouveauté dans le cartable le
taille crayon en forme de bombe à
essence en 1965
petite révolution dans les salles de
classe pour la première fois le stylo à
bille est autorisée grâce à un décret du
gouvernement
résultat les fabricants profitent de
l'occasion et tente de trouver le stylo
qui va plaire aux enfants
n'oublions pas les gadgets de la rentée
scolaire le gros crayon à bille au 15
couleurs incorporer le crayon japonais
la trousse officiers le sac de cours
la serviette voyageurs à la fin des
années 80 un nouveau phénomène est
observé l'enfant est transformé en ce
qu'on pourrait appeler un homme sandwich
de la publicité apparaît sur les
fournitures scolaires à l'image de la
trousse hollywood et du cartable coca
cola cette année ce qu'on voit
apparaître par rapport à l'année
dernière c'est ce sont les marques c'est
à dire des classeurs des agendas
scolaires des choses comme ça des
trousses qui sont faites avec des
marques de vêtements de boissons de
chewing gum des fournitures coloré et
attrayante pour l'enfant souvent plus
chers pour les parents autre
inconvénient de ces produits ils peuvent
créer des rivalités entre les élèves et
les distraire dans leur travail ils sont
sous forme de jouets il amusé les
enfants ils peuvent être saisis dans les
en sépare les enseignants notamment et
il complique la vie scolaire
les années passent et les modes changent
en 2001 harry potter est à l'honneur les
enfants se ruent sur la trousse à
l'effigié du célèbre sorcier
son prix 59 francs soit six fois plus
cher qu'un article 1er prix des produits
souvent mieux exposés exemple dans ce
magasin parisien où rien n'était laissé
au hasard
c'est un emplacement stratégique puisque
c'est le moral et les extrêmement
colorés donc la cliente lorsqu'elle est
dans l'allée le voit et va vers son
univers cette rentrée 2020 devrait aussi
voir apparaître de nouvelles tendances
cette mode a un prix selon l'association
familles de france le coût moyen des
fournitures scolaire d'un élève de 6e
s'élever à près de 196 euros en 2019
[Musique]